Ahora tenemos una situación realmente interesante,
tenemos nuestra balanza en la cual
tenemos nuestra masa misteriosa,
esta vez la llame "y",
para hacer notar que no siempre
es necesario llamarle "x",
se puede usar cualquier símbolo siempre y
cuando podamos darle seguimiento en el desarrollo.
También tenemos masas de un kilogramo
en ambos lados de la balanza.
Y lo primero que voy a hacer,
es desarrollar todos los pasos necesarios
para encontrar el valor
de la masa misteriosa "y"
y me gustaría invitarte a ver si tú eres capaz de expresar esto de una manera algebraica
utilizando notación matemática,
una expresión que describa
la situación que tenemos aquí,
de este lado tengo 3 masas "y"
y 3 masas de 1 kilogramo
y su masa total es igual a este lado en donde
tengo una masa "y" y 7 masas de 1 kilogramo,
piénsalo por unos segundos.
Veamos la masa total de este lado,
tengo 3 masas "y",
que son "3y"
y 3 masas de 1 kilogramo...
y de este lado tengo 1 masas "y"...
que lo escribo como "y"...
o bueno, podría poner "1y",
pero como es lo mismo no lo utilizamos
y tengo 7 masasde 1 kilogramo, a ver...
tengo 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
sí, efectivamente son "y" más 7 y la balanza
está en equilibrio,
o sea, la masa total de ambos lados es la misma, entonces podemos escribir un símbolo igual
y ya logramos lo que queríamos,
tenemos una expresión para
esta situación de la vida real.
Hay situaciones en que la gente quiere encontrar
la masa de objetos desconocidos,
por ejemplo cuando vas a una joyería
y habrá que saber resolverlo
y ya logramos construir
una expresión matemática para esto.
Ahora la pregunta sería,
¿cuáles serían los pasos razonables para
continuar solucionando este problema?
Y me gustaría darte unos segundos
para que lo pienses.
Algo maravilloso que tiene el álgebra es que podemos abordar los problemas de diferentes formas,
por ejemplo podríamos pensar,
¿qué tal si quitamos estos 3 bloques
de 1 kg de ambos lados?
o ¿qué tal si quitamos
1 "y" de ambos lados?
No importa el orden en el que
hagamos los pasos...
pues escojamos alguno de ellos,
pues que tal si empezamos quitando
una "y" de ambos lados,
de esta manera lograremos tener nada más
de un lado a las "y"
y recuerda tenemos que hacerlo de los dos lados,
si nada más quitáramos una "y" de un lado,
la balanza ya no estaría en equilibrio.
Entonces lo vamos a hacer de los dos lados
de la balanza y vamos a quitar una masa "y"...
a ver, la quitamos...
y lo voy a hacer con este color morado...
Ahora,
¿cómo se vería esto de manera algebraica?
O sea, yo quité una "y" del lado izquierdo y
entonces quito una "y" del lado derecho
y de hecho eso es lo que hice en la balanza,
quite una "y",
no sé cuanto pesa pero yo
quité una de cada lado,
entonces veamos que tenemos,
lo podemos ver matemáticamente,
o sea, si yo tenía 3 y quito 1 o también
lo podemos ver aquí en el dibujo,
si de los 3 quito 1,
entonces me quedan dos "y".
Y se aprecia, yo tenía 3 quite 1
y me quedan 2
y claro los demás cubos permanecen aquí,
por ejemplo los amarillos.
Ahora vamos al otro lado,
entonces yo nada más tenía una "y"
y la quité entonces ya no está de este lado,
solo tengo las masas amarillas.
Entonces si yo a "y" le quito una "y",
ya no hay más "y" y mantengo mis 7 bloques amarillos.
Y veamos, nuestra balanza está en equilibrio,
si yo quité la misma masa de ambos lados,
el equilibrio permanece.
Así que estas 2 cosas que tenemos aquí
serán iguales
y se empieza a ver muy similar
a nuestro último video.
Y aquí te pregunto,
¿qué podríamos seguir haciendo
para simplificar esto que tenemos aquí?
O sea, poder aislar nada más a las "y" del
lado izquierdo, piénsalo unos segundos.
Bueno, si lo que queremos es eliminar el 3
que tenemos de este lado,
entonces tendríamos que quitar
los 3 bloques de este lado,
pero también tendríamos que quitar los del otro lado para mantener el equilibrio,
así que quitamos 3 de este lado
y 3 de este lado
o sea que estamos restando de este lado 3 y
de este lado estamos restando 3.
En el lado izquierdo,
entonces solo nos van a quedar estas 2 masas de "y",
o sea que solo tenemos "2y",
pues 3 menos 3 es 0
y nos quedan como aquí se puede ver "2y"
y en el lado derecho también quitamos 3 bloques,
o sea que nos quedan 4, solo tenemos 4.
Entonces las 2 masas "y" es igual a 4 kg
y como hicimos las mismas cosas
en ambos lados de la balanza, el equilibrio se conserva.
Y ahora,
¿cómo resolvemos esto?
Bueno, lo más probable es
que lo puedes hacer con tu mente,
si tengo 2 veces algo que es igual a 4... bueno,
pero siguiendo con la mecánica que hemos hecho,
vamos a regresar y pensarlo
como lo veníamos haciendo.
Si yo aquí tengo estas 2 cosas que es igual
a los objetos que están del otro lado,
¿qué tal si multiplicamos
ambos lados por 1/2?
O lo que es lo mismo,
dividir cada lado entre 2,
que sería equivalente a tomar la mitad
de la masa que está de cada lado.
Entonces, si yo tomo la mitad de la masa que está aquí, solo me quedará una "y"
y de este otro lado si tomo la mitad de la masa
solo me quedarán 2 bloques de 1 kg.
¿Y qué fue lo que hice?
Bueno, si lo vemos aquí abajo sería lo mismo
pensar que lo multipliqué por 1/2
ó que lo dividí entre 2
y entonces del lado izquierdo me queda solo una "y"
y del lado derecho me queda un 2.
Y puedo poner el símbolo de igual porque
la balanza sigue en equilibrio,
o sea, tomé la mitad de lo que había en ambos lados
y si estaba en equilibrio,
al yo quitar la mitad de ambos lados
pues sigue en equilibrio.
Y lo logramos, logramos resolver algo que
al inicio no se veía fácil de resolver
y ahora sabemos que la
masa misteriosa "y" vale 2
y podemos comprobarlo,
que esto es algo fascinante del álgebra.
Podemos regresar al problema inicial
y ver si tiene sentido y vamos a hacerlo,
vamos a comprobar si la respuesta que obtuvimos
tiene sentido en el problema original
y esta vez me gustaría que tú lo hicieras,
si ya sabemos que la masa desconocida vale 2,
habrá que calcular la masa total de cada lado,
aquí tengo un 2, otro 2 y otro 2, que me dan 6
más estos 3 que tengo aquí arriba, me da 9.
Y del lado derecho tengo estos 7 que están
aquí más 2 que vale éste, 7 más 2 es 9,
tenemos 9 kg en ambos lados.